smellorama no raheem alhamdulillahi
[Arabic recitation]
rasulillah early he was happy here
la sharika lahu al la sala him ash hadu
[Arabic recitation]
muhammad while he was happy he ajma'in
and my bad today insha'Allah Allah
continuing with our theme that we had
begun previously and that is we are
going to be discussing and kind of
wrapping up some of the issues with
regards to popular superstitions and
their ruling with Allah Subhanahu WA
Ta'ala and last week we discussed a
number of superstitions and most
prominently last week we discussed the
issue of magic sip we discussed some of
the descriptions because as we know said
as we mentioned last week in detail a
sip in the Arabic language this this
this word is defined Sahaba seeing how
of these three letters when they come
together and they're combined in this in
this order they articulate an act which
is undetectable
they articulate an act or a time that is
hidden or undetectable right and this is
where we get the word south from Sahab
is the time right before fudge Allah
when we have our so when we have our
Sahul
right so whole it is taken from the same
root word and the scene to have the law
because it is because it is a time that
is dark and what people are doing during
that time is generally private and
hidden all right
likewise a sip which in the Book of
Allah articulates those acts of
transgression against others those acts
of transgression against others which
are hidden and that act is done by way
of spells or essentially what boils down
to the worship of other than a loss of
Hanna with Adam and we discussed last
week in in pretty good detail the
different types of things which Islam
considers to be types of sin so we
mentioned that a sit in the legislation
of Islam is kind of a broad umbrella
kind of broad umbrella term which is
inclusive of many things right and one
of those things is what comes to mind
when we think of magic what comes to
mind when we think of Sahel which is you
know which is and so forth
that type of set specifically meaning
sip magic that are entails the worship
of other than a law this set is a type
of cool according to the book of allah
subhana wa tada if it are if it entails
the worship of other than Allah what
does that mean as we know human beings
and jinn they are the two creatures on
this earth which are which are expected
to worship allah subhana wa ta'ala and
to exercise their free will in the
obedience of allah we are the only two
creatures on this earth the human being
and the jinn who have total free will
and have the ability to do right or
wrong according to the legislation of
Allah this is why in the correct opinion
of the scholars the Prophet Muhammad SAW
alone on Uwe Salem was only sent to the
humankind in the gym and not sent to the
Angels now the angels on a side note
they do have free will but they do not
have a desire to disobey allah subhanho
wa taala contrary to the human being and
the jinn they do not have that internal
struggle rights of the flesh and the
spirit both tugging at them one part of
them wants to do something wrong the
other part says no they don't have this
internal struggle right so these two
creatures the human being in the gym
they have the ability to complement one
another meaning that the human being can
do things that the jinn cannot
necessarily do and the jinn can do
things that the human being cannot
necessarily do and if we look in the
book of a loss of Hanna with a data we
will notice a pattern and that is
whenever a loss of Hanna Matata wishes
to discuss or bring up the subject of
the human being and the gym together in
the same sentence or in the same context
if he is referring to strength and might
right or military he will begin with the
gym he will say in the gym well ince so
he'll start with the gym because they
are more powerful physically and more
able right wha-ho schiavelli sulaymana
do who mean as a jitney well in what by
and if when a loss of hand Matata wishes
to discuss the human being in the gym
but is speaking about articulation
speaking about I am speaking about
eloquence in speech and precision in
articulation of meaning and emotion
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala will begin with
the human being and then the jinn as
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala sedgwick adela
kajal nelly Kulina being I do when
shelton l MC well Jenna yo hey Baba whom
Allah burdens o coca-cola Aurora and so
this is the these are the dynamics the
human being is more
the human being is more articulate the
human being is more eloquent human being
is more able to express very fine
detailed nuanced meanings whereas the
Djinn are more powerful in their bodies
and their abilities their physical
capabilities and so when the human being
interacts with the Djinn this is
something that is very very rare okay
now when we discuss the issue of magic
when we discuss the issue of said we
have to keep in mind that this is not
the norm this is the exception
it exists yes and there are in fact
which is not the witches that we
probably imagine you know the the old
lady with the green skin and the black
hat you know and and stirring this pot
of stew this is this is what we're told
you know in imagery and in in you know
popular culture we are speaking about
men and women that look just me and
you they may even go to the Masjid they
may pray they may and oftentimes do in
Muslim countries masquerade s shares as
people of knowledge as people of
people who are righteous people Ryan
people that are humble and this is kind
of a dust cloud to conceal what it is
that they are really doing men or women
right though women are usually more
prone to this at least in the time of
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
and this is something that exists but
again it is the exception it is not the
majority when we learn about the fact
that a Shaitaan can possess a person
this is an issue which is mentioned in
the Quran and it is alluded to in the
Quran and when we discuss magic and the
fact that spell could be used or placed
on someone when we discuss these things
this is not the most likely culprit and
our problems and this is a problem that
we have very often and that is that
people generally as human beings we are
very complacent we don't to take
responsibility and so we often look for
the easy way out
and that is to point our fingers at
others and so if a person has let's say
problems in his marriage they will try
to they'll go to the ship and say you
know what
I think my wife is possessed right I
think my wife is possessed she wasn't
acting this before now she's acting
this or the other way around
right or somebody has done some magic on
us or somebody has given us the evil eye
again while possible it is very
improbable it's possible and it does
happen on occasion but it's not as
widespread as popular culture would have
you believe it is kind of rare it does
happen but it is not the cause of our
troubles usually there is a more likely
culprit it's kind of it's kind of
when a person has an illness right
if a person starts to feel they
have a cold now the symptoms of a cold
or the symptoms of a flu they are
somewhat ambiguous it could be a whole
plethora of illnesses that could cause
this right it could be anything from
just a simple cold or even sinuses
acting up because you were in a dusty
environment all the way up to things
heart attack and cancer and
leukemia and all of these things it
could be anywhere in between but when we
go to diagnose something we don't jump
to the most rare thing when somebody
said I feel I have flu-like
symptoms we don't say well you probably
have leukemia
we don't usually go there right we begin
with things that are most likely most
probable if a person has a problem in
his marriage okay yes it is
hypothetically possible that this could
be some outside interference right of
magic or something but most likely most
likely the problems are coming from one
or both of the two spouses all right
that is the most likely culprit and so
in when it comes to the issue of
likewise when it comes to the issue of
psychosis people people have psychosis
people have things schizophrenia
right now we have to diagnose things
physically and medically before we jump
to the conclusion that this is some kind
of demonic possession right we have to
go through those steps first because
they are more likely and if we look at
the sunnah of the prophet sallallaahu a
said in his life is true did we see that
that was less dwelled upon and the
prophets all alone he was sending them
did mention these things to health
explain to us the world around us and to
emphasize the things that are unseen and
the things that are spiritual because
that is what he came to address mainly
soul Aloha Ewa Salem however we do not
see that he most often in diagnosing
people's problems would jump to the
conclusion of possession or evil eye or
any of these things it happens and it
did occur in the time of the prophets
all alone onto a set and he would
mention it but it is not as frequent as
people would have he belief as people
would have us believe and so you know
I've had all kinds of situations I've
had people call me and try to convince
me that you know he he divorced his wife
he divorced her three times but she
should still be his wife because there's
some kind of magic spell on her
and she's possessed and that's what
caused him to divorce her so it's the
jinns fault right it's somebody else's
fault Sibley's his fault it's not my
fault and that's really not going to fly
on the day of resurrection either as
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says well i'm
marco de la mora Carla Carla shape our
new lemnoc OD el amor en a la hora de
comunidad happy vodka left o co filete
new moon evil omen full circle mana be
mostly cumin and to be mostly loss of
Hannah what Alice said that when
everybody is where he belongs in
Paradise or the Hellfire at the end and
everybody is in his place and and Allah
is finished with his judgment Elise will
say to his followers Allah promised you
and I promised you and I I was not true
to my promise
don't blame me blame yourselves I did
not have any physical abilities to
control you nor did you over me I just I
just invited you i beckoned you I
insinuated I whispered to you I
encouraged you but you did it with your
own free will you exercised your own
free will to do these things so don't
blame me and blame yourselves and so we
have to take responsibility for our
actions
and this is one of the most important
principles of finding guidance and that
is taking responsibility for our actions
and so when we discuss ahead we are more
if you notice we are more we are
dwelling upon more of the things which
happen to every one of us like
superstitions talismans like
rituals things that that we all do
for good luck or to ward off bad luck or
what have you that are part of SIF in
the general sense right and we are not
speaking about possession and these
things as much because it's more rare
okay so the way that real magic works
the magic that is mentioned in The Book
of Allah which a person is considered a
witch which will invalidate a person's
it's name is is a type of magic which
entails the worship of other than Allah
[Arabic recitation]
so essentially as we mentioned the human
being is more eloquent the jinn is more
physically capable and so the human
being may have the way that real
magicians real witches get into this is
that they are expected to perform
rituals and worship of certain jinn in
order to receive services from them
right
not Jin more shayateen demons they
worship these demons they will slaughter
for other than Allah they will pray to
these demons and
everything that you can imagine that or
cannot imagine that is terrible
is usually something that these people
are expected to do in order to gain the
services of these shell team and so they
are expected to not bathe for for a
month they are expected to chant the
praises of certain demons or certain
shayateen they are expected to defile
the hold on defile religion right they
are expected to sometimes bathe in
impurities and in filth they are
expected on occasion to sleep in amongst
garbage all kinds of things to degrade
the magician and to Train the magician
to serve in a in a religious sense other
than a loss of Hannibal attack
and in return they may receive certain
aid from particular jinn or demons or
shayateen that will perform for them
things that seem to be unbelievable
things that seem to be very supernatural
right
and so this type of magic is rare but it
is something that exists but this is not
all that is meant by magic one of the
things that we'll mention today is
another thing that falls into the
general meaning of the general umbrella
of magic in the legislation of Islam
according to the slams definition and
that is the issue of astrology this is
very very common in this culture
astrology what is astrology well let's
read the narration first is the
narration of IBN abas radiyallahu anhu
ma Pilate allah rasool allah he
sallallahu alayhi wasallam many Tabitha
sherbet and Meena know to me a charlatan
a para feynman al menos una vaca dr.
Bosher botany Nasseri Zelda Masada Oahu
up with the wood what is inaudible so
here and so this narration Abdullah
heaven our death or the loved ones on
that near rates that the messenger of
allah sallallahu alayhi wasallam said
whoever learns a portion of whoever
learns any portion of the discipline if
you want to call it that or the science
of astrology which which it's not it's
more of a superstition then this
individual has learned a portion of
magic according to the Book of Allah
they and the more he learns of it the
more he learns of magic in real even
realistic and this is in reality and
this is a method that the Prophet SAW
Allah WA Nimal seldom used to denounce
something too
to dispraise something to dispraise
something we the prophets all alone I
Lewis Elam will either outwardly
dispraise it or he will liken it to
something which has been displaced right
so here he mentions astrology is a
portion of magic and we know in the Book
of Allah that magic ass it is something
which is a major sin and is dispraised
throughout the Book of Allah and the
Sunnah of the Prophet SAW Allah on the
centre-right this is one of the ways
that the Prophet Muhammad SAW Malone wa
salem would prohibit something and that
is to not directly dispraise it but to
liken it to something which is displaced
or mentioned that it is a portion or a
part of something which is displaced
another good example of this is the
narration of a narration in Sahih Muslim
in which the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam I said men lava Ben note the
sheet faka animal a messiah who fee
Lakme in ziran what emma he he said soul
alone he wa sallam whoever plays with
dice dice whoever uses dice plays with
dice then it is as if he has stuck his
hand into the blood and flesh of swine
now what do we know of the blood and
flesh of swine it is filthy
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala mentions it by
name it is the only animal mentioned by
name in the Quran and prohibited by name
right other animals that are prohibited
to eat or consume
are mentioned by description or mention
in the Sunnah in the pull on the the pig
the swine is mentioned by name over and
over and over so when the prophet
muhammad salih loan on to a settler
makes a connection between playing dice
and this thing which is mentioned by
allah to be filthy and prohibited and
interaction with dice is like
interaction with this flesh of this
swine and the blood of the swine we see
that this is a way that he is dis
praising this thing that it is
prohibited this is one of the ways that
he will articulate prohibition so la
llamada he Wasilla in the science of
well-suited felt and so here we have a
dispraise of astrology now there is a
difference between astrology and
astronomy right astronomy is the science
of studying the Stars as they are
physically alright their positions and
what they represent and what they do and
looking through telescopes this is the
astronomer right the astrologer this is
ancient superstition which goes back to
the days of Babylon perhaps even
predates Babylonian days and that is
looking to the stars
as indicators or cause causes of things
that occur on earth this is astrology
according to a lots of panel without as
definition the prophets all alone our
newest items definition
horoscopes looking to the stars -
for good luck looking to the stars to
see the future all of these things that
we see people do this is a type of said
this is a type of set in Islam this is
called astrology this is absolutely
prohibited in Islam
yes Allah subhana WA Ta'ala has made
constellations in the sky but these
constellations which are referred to as
you know the crab and the bowl and this
is not something that is part of Islamic
knowledge this is a superstition which
is derived from paganism in our popular
culture our in America our version of
astrology and our take on the
constellations are for the most part
taken from ancient Roman culture and
their worship of other than Allah and
their gods
just as our days of the week are in our
months our and other things because you
know American culture Western cultures
is very much a descendant and
a an extension of that ancient culture
and so people would look to these stars
in these constellations if you're born
in this month this is what your
horoscope says and you know it's a
fun quirky thing that's in all of the
newspapers or a lot of newspapers right
we've got your weekly horoscope so
you're going to look at this horoscope
let's check out which month you were
born and this is what you can expect
your month or your week to be or
your day this is absolutely a type of
in Islam this is a type of
astrology and set in Islam and this is
something which is prohibited
likewise what is what is another type of
magic
another type of magic is a Kahana which
is in English what we refer to as
soothsayers or fortune tellers right
there are two types that are mentioned
in the Sun now there are the cohan
German occasion and there are the a la
foon the German Lavrov and some scholars
of Islam mentioned that the Canon and
outlaw are the same thing
others mentioned that occasion is one
who tries to allegedly predict the
future for you I'll tell you what your
future holds and the our love is someone
you go to who claims to know the unseen
of things which are now things which are
occurring now nothing to do with the
future this is the distinction what do
we call them we call them mediums right
we call them psychics in in English or
in America anyways we call them psychics
a psychic is someone who can tell you
you know I can tell you what you're
thinking or what so-and-so is thinking
or what is happening or what your dead
parent is telling you or what the other
side right these are called mediums and
psychics or oftentimes
this a broth when people go missing or
used they are used in our as a matter of
fact the American government had for a
time during the Cold War experimented
with psychics right and the the point is
is that often times when people go
missing when there is a cold case a
murder case that can't be that that the
detectives where the family members
reach a kind of dead end or reach a
brick wall they can't take it any
further the case is going cold they will
resort to things psychics or
mediums who and there's other as well
psychics mediums remote viewing right
these things are all part of Gehenna
well raffia this is all part of what
Islam considers to be psychics mediums
remote remote remote viewers all of
these things psychic is someone who
usually claims that they can look into
the future right
a avila off or a medium is someone who
usually speaks about what the dead are
saying right and we see these on our
daytime talk shows I mean anyways when I
was a kid in the 90s this is what we
were watching you know the Montel
Williams Show and the
you know all these other talk shows
where they would bring these psychics on
I remember Montel
I remember Montel was was a popular one
because he used to bring a particular
woman who's deceased now all of the time
and they would choose audience members
and I'm seeing an S in the name
well yeah you will see an S in someone's
name somewhere along the line because
that's a very popular consonant in the
English language anyways these people
mediums would claim to speak with the
spirit world or claim to speak with the
dead right the deceased likewise we have
remote viewing remote viewing is you're
sitting here but you are seeing another
part of the world right you are seeing
another part of the world and you can
tell people where their lost sibling is
where their kidnapped child is may Allah
protect us where who is the person who
killed someone etc etc now these things
these types of people are known as Glenn
now this doesn't mean that allah subhana
wa ta'ala cannot give a person a dream
on occasion right a person may go to
sleep a person of righteousness and
perhaps have a premonition this is
something that is can be from a loss of
hano ITAT happened in the time of the
Companions there's a difference between
that and someone who claims to be a
person who can do this at will whenever
they desire whenever they choose this is
a completely different thing right and
so
astrology is a type of sin in Islam
psychics mediums Auto Fein these
different types of people what is the
ruling of interacting and visiting these
types of people in its left well we have
a narration collected by Lima Muslim on
the authority of the wife of the prophet
sallallaahu a Salem in which the Prophet
sallallahu wasallam I said Minetta are
often fella who I'm shade in facade
alcohol and took the level salah or by
in ailment
he said sallallahu alayhi wasallam
whoever approaches a soothsayer or the
scholars of Islam have taken as
soothsayers works right so for example
if a person looks at the horoscope they
haven't gone to the actual astrologer
who claimed who claims knowledge of the
future through via these horoscopes they
haven't gone to that person but they
have gone to that person's words or that
person's works right and that is the
same thing in Islam that is why when
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala speaks about the
Sunnah he speaks about the prophet
muhammed sallalahu said he mentions if
we differ in anything we are to refer
back to Allah back to his messenger what
does that mean the book of allah the
words of allah of the words of the
messenger so allah on the senate
likewise we will have been considered to
have referred something back to allah
right
referred something back to the messenger
of allah so allah in the center likewise
if a person reads the books or the
horoscopes or the predictions of those
who claim to be psychics or mediums or
fortune tellers or
whatever it is astrologers that this
person has the same ruling is one who
physically goes to them and interacts
with them it is the same thing the
prophets Allah loan you asylum says
whoever goes to a rough and we mention a
bluff is our equivalent today of a
remote viewer or a medium and asked him
acts asks him or her about anything and
then believe anything having to do with
with that field right not asking a
psychic the time what time is it
they have a watch on their hand that's
not what it's intended what is intended
is what they claim to be prominent in
and that is knowing the unseen asks them
about anything having to do with the
unseen or their claims to such knowledge
and believes what this person has said
LEM took the level salah out of a nal
men their prayer will not be accepted by
a law for 40 days 40 days right and this
doesn't mean that the person stops
praying
no you must pray but the prayer is not
going to be rewarding it is not going to
be accepted by Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
as a punishment for this and a
repercussion
likewise Abu Dawood the suggests tani
has collected on the authority of Allah
right about the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam I said men attack a
demon for Sadako be my whole
[Arabic recitation]
alayhi wasallam affiliate in manator
Arafah no K&N for Sadako be my full
focus Cara be my own seal allah muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam so he said in
another wording of this narration he
said so lalomanu asylum the Prophet said
whoever goes to a medium or a psychic or
fortune-teller and believes what days
tell him
then this individual has disbelieved in
what has been sent down upon muhammad
sallallaahu ascend the religion of islam
this person has done something that will
invalidate at least a portion of a
person's Islam and so the scholars of
Islam mentioned between these two
narrations that this person has
disbelieved in what has been sent down
upon Muhammad soul alone on the asylum
and the other wording Allah will not
accept his or her prayer for forty days
this articulates that this is a type of
minor that is asking looking at
what they say or even worse believing in
what they say that this will invalidate
a portion of a person's descent it will
not make a person a non Muslim but it is
a thing that will invalidate a portion
of a person's Islam which is a very
serious thing very very serious thing
and so
what falls into this fortune cookies
horoscopes psychics mediums all of these
types of people and their works that
claim to make particular predictions
this is a type of this this has this
same ruling that we have just mentioned
there is a narration also on the
authority of an Milanovic assign more
foreign colonies eminent Ohio totally
erotic Ahana otaku he narrow our Sarah I
will show here whenever I'm an attack a
Heenan force a dacha will be my pocket
[Arabic recitation]
sallallahu alayhi wasallam or level
Bazaar be snared in jagged
another narration on the authority of
ramalon even Hussein in which the near
the prophet muhammad salih loan money wa
salem was narrated to have said he is
not of us the one who looks for bad
omens or has bad omens sought for and we
spoke about it totally right or to
Kahana otaku in a level someone who goes
to the psychic or or someone who sends
another to go to the psychic on his
behalf or one that does magic or one
that has magic done for him this
individual is not of us right he's
speaking of himself soul alone you were
said if he is not of a lot his messenger
solo mahadeva said right he says women
attacking an foe Sadako be my ooh la la
be my ooh nila ala muhammadin soul alone
you are selling and whoever goes to a
soothsayer a fortune-teller a medium a a
psychic a remote viewer right
and believes this individual in what he
says then this individual has
disbelieved in what has been sent down
upon Muhammad sallallahu alayhi wasallam
and so this is what we wanted basically
to speak about today come to Allah with
regards to some very very prominent
things in our culture that happened so
these things involve palm reading
right palm reading these things involve
horoscopes these this ruling this thing
which is we've spoken about today
involves fortune tellers mediums
psychics magicians and also other things
that we have spoken about before with
regards to the stars if a person looks
to the stars as things that interact
with our earth we have no physical
proof of this or we have no legislative
proof of this an outline is messenger
did not tell us and we cannot detect any
physical evidence of this then this is
also type of let's - ship in its then so
for example it is believed that when a
certain star is out that this is a good
omen or if a certain star is out it will
bring rain or it will cause it to rain
right there is a fine line there and
that is if it is not a if it is not an
an issue having to do with astronomy
meaning that when the when the earth is
on a particular when it is towards
whichever axis or what have you there's
a physical formula that we can prove and
we can disprove scientifically that this
is something which correlates with this
that is different right so for example
well what does this mean the full moon
okay the full moon by something which
has a lot of superstition connected to
it and it also has some astronomical
meaning there in the science of gravity
and pull and astronomy there is a real
physical interaction so we can see that
on the full moon and everyone crabs in
certain tropical islands to come
out during that time innate right this
is when they do it correlates with the
full moon we see that the tide
the tide of the oceans and seas because
of the gravitational pull of the moon
interacts with these tides and causes
the tide to rise that is fine there's
other things even even things with
regards to our blood pressure and so
forth if there is a physical and
detectable thing right we can detect it
physically we can measure it we can
disprove it most importantly this is
fine but connecting a full moon to
werewolves for example other
superstitions then this is not something
which is permissible right so there are
superstitions and there are things which
are physically proven if a if a magician
says tomorrow you're going to have
such-and-such happen to you a
fortune-teller that is different than
the weatherman saying you know we're
gonna have rain tomorrow most likely 99%
chance we're looking at the clouds we're
looking at we are measuring certain
things and we are making a prediction
that is fine but this other thing which
we cannot prove and most importantly we
cannot disprove this is something which
is a superstition so there is a
difference likewise if you if you go to
a you know a soothsayer or a magician or
they said they fortune-teller or psychic
they tell you yes your your child is you
know going to be this and datsan going
to be a girl
this is prohibited and how long and has
the meanings and the the rulings that we
have just mentioned but if you go to
your doctor and get a
all to get an ultrasound this is
permissible because we have a detectable
way of looking at something this is not
magic anymore right so that is enough
for today we'll lower limb or someone
Louis endomondo nabina muhammad where he
was happiest man hundred